last night during Grey's Anatomy
shaundalyn consumed by Ola Davis Allen
Pompeo talking about Hillary Clinton
being both brilliant and flawed and it
was directed by scandals commander in
chief Tony Goldwyn and he told us how it
all came together definition that came
from the Clinton campaign and we're
talking to Shonda Rhimes about what we
could all do together I make television
filled with the kind of characters I
imagine we all can be strong but flawed
human but extraordinary we shot the
Pisan in less than a day
everyone just cleared the time and it
was pretty inspiring our characters are
on television but the real world the
real world has Hillary Clinton directing
this commercial was so wonderful because
everybody was there for the simple
reason that they have a development
necessity to speak out about about
something they feel strongly about
I'm with Hillary the new ad comes just
weeks after the presidential hopeful
visited the set of scandal meanwhile
Donald Trump's Hollywood circle is
growing the former producer and TV star
is supported by conservative Clint
Eastwood and just this week after Jon
Voight endorsed the Republican
frontrunner